We are planning to knit a
cute little drop shoulder tee.
Now this could be a child's Pinafore
or something else, but the front is
knit in one piece and we want the yoke
section in a different stitch pattern.
Now we know that two stitch patterns
are going to have very different gauge.
Let's take a look at how
to best approach this
so our Tee ends up the right size.
I'm not going to bore you with the math.
Trust me, and just follow along
and follow the logic here.
We'll knit the lower half of the
sweater in our first stitch pattern.
Let's say stockinette at 20 stitches
to four inches or 10 centimeters
or seven stitches to the inch.
Let's ignore the
difference in rows for now.
According to the pattern, when
we get to the yoke section the
knitting will measure 16 inches.
At this gauge, this
translates to 112 stitches.
We've swatched and we've established
that our lace gauge is 24 stitches
to four inches, so instead of
seven stitches to the inch, we're
looking at six stitches to the inch.
So if we continue knitting over the
112 stitches and we knit in the lace
pattern, the yoke's going to end up
being more than 18 inches wide instead
of the desired 16 this could make
the piece really wonky and not fit.
So what has to happen?
When it's time to switch and
start knitting the lace pattern,
we need to decrease some stitches.
How many?
16 inches at six stitches per inch
would be 96 stitches, not 112 so we
need to decrease 16 stitches evenly.
How would you do that?
One way would be to remove the
knitting from the bed with a garter
bar or scrap yarn and then rehang the
work over the 96 needles, doubling
up stitches evenly across the bed.
Then you could continue
knitting in the lace pattern
and it would be the right size.
But there definitely will be
a road differences as well.
Now, if you hate math as much as I do,
there's an easier way to calculate how
many stitches to decrease and have the
row counts and the shaping accurate too.
Just build your Knit it Now pattern twice.
Once at each gauge, the pattern will
tell you the number of stitches at
the stockinette gauge and the number
of stitches at the lace gauge.
Plus it will give you accurate row
counts for the lace section as well,
based on your row gauge in lace.
So start knitting with pattern
1at the stockinette gauge and then
switch to pattern 2 decreasing
stitches according to the pattern and
complete the yoke using pattern 2.
If you do this, you're guaranteed
that your knitting will end up the
right size and your sweater will fit.